would you rather have it dick as your
nose or her nose as your dick definitely
a nose as my dick because then you could
blow my nose and I don't want to upset
you but I'm not on antibiotics but it's
viral take them anyway
kids if you people tell you don't take
antibiotics because it's not bacteria
they're full of [ __ ] take drugs no
matter what and stay in school
would you rather orgasm every time you
hear all-star buy smash mouth or hear
all-star every time you orgasm I I don't
want to be at the mercy of Smash Mouth
in public so I think I'd rather orgasm
every time I heard all-star buy Smash
Mouth but then I would just have to cry
which I do already when I orgasm would
you rather have hotdogs for fingers or
hamburgers or butt cheeks that's tough
man that's tough
I'd say Burger cheeks yeah burger cheese
yeah yeah burger cheese
grease up the toilet seat would you
rather [ __ ] and go and nobody knows or
you don't [ __ ] go but everybody
because you didn't know I've heard this
[ __ ] before oh man I've thought about
this one I I don't think I don't think I
could ever [ __ ] ago I couldn't like I'm
cool with everyone thinking I [ __ ] a
goat that's fine with me dude like come
on I've done some weird [ __ ] like
everyone thinks I have a micropenis but
that was true
would you rather [ __ ] yourself every
time you have an orgasm or get a random
boner every time you talk to a dude
I would rather [ __ ] myself every time I
had an orgasm I already do yeah but
that's a double orgasm because taking a
[ __ ] is fantastic it's orgasmic yeah
right you just be like I mean that's the
ultimate pleasure orgasm is [ __ ] at the
same time get right down to it this is a
super easy question yeah yeah that's
what's stupid about the question is how
easy it is
would you rather say on a cake and eat a
dick or sit on a dick and eat a cake I
would rather sit on a cake and eat a
dick but like you know like suck it
right not like eat it okay yeah yeah I'd
rather I'd rather I'd rather sit on the
cake and eat a dick because I I really
like second day we got through that who
would win a fight a Navy SEALs brain or
a toddler's body or a toddler's body in
a seals body a Navy SEALs brain hmm I'm
going with the baby you're building your
dick from scratch you make it as big as
you want but for every inch you add you
lose two years off your life how big do
you make it dude I'm cool with I got 75
would you rather have a 10-inch dick
with no balls or a 4-inch stick with
balls of course I want to have the big
dick energy I want the 10-inch dick with
no balls
I'm just getting aware aren't they
uncomfortable manage all day don't think
it hot don't you powder them I don't
want the extra stuff I'd rather just
have the 10 inch test she'll knock that
thing well I mean I'm not into 4-inch
dicks either so I have fact
extra extra yeah you have to learn about
the balls as a girl like would you [ __ ]
the ugliest teacher you ever had yes
oh is that not the question Oh would you
[ __ ] the obvious teacher ever had to
[ __ ] the hottest teacher you ever had
yeah listen most guys would [ __ ] the
other teacher they ever had just for the
story then that's a hard no that's
that's a hard pass there was a dude
there was a teacher that I had whose
body odor was so bad but he also used to
stand
he had chest hair and he had his shirt
button too here and he would talk to you
and he would twirl the chest hair and
slowly rip it out of his chest and
sprinkle it on the ground in front of
him and his bow hey smell that dude
smells so bad and he always had food in
his beard
there was one time he had a piece of
cheese in his [ __ ] eyebrow and I was
just staring at him like what am I doing
here
yeah so I would say no would you rather
walk in on your dad having sex with a
dog or your dog having sex with your dad
neither I'd rather see my dad starring
in the mr. hands video [ __ ] no one knows
what that one is
that's where the horse [ __ ] a guy to
death sorry I should have said that
instead of trying to be all highbrow
with the actual title your mom and
girlfriend switched bodies only way to
get them back to normal is to bang one
of them who do you have sex with to
think about my mom with my [ __ ]
girlfriends Puerto Rican ass is the
funniest thing I've ever thought of what
to think about my mom having a tattoo on
her tit it's hilarious but who do I bang
out I guess I'll see um I guess I bang I
bang my girl with my mom's body cuz
that's just like that's just like yeah I
would do that cuz my mom yeah yeah
because my really nan and I don't know
now I can't bang anything it looks like
my yeah
your mom and girlfriend switched bodies
the only way to get them back to normal
is you have to bang one of them who do
you have sex with so either way I'm
kinda having sex with my mom my mom went
to an Ivy League school so you know what
I'm changing yeah absolutely I don't
know this is [ __ ] nice smart brain
I'd like to bang that out you know this
is the tough this is a hard question
well she knows that we had sex yeah yeah
my mom yeah it's having sex with my
mom's body yeah at this point yeah she's
66 it's like yeah it's like having sex
with my dad's body's the same body at
this point you know but she they're
aware of it they're cool I guess I still
have sex I'd have sex with my I'd have
sex with my girlfriend's brain in my
mom's body yeah why not and [ __ ] it yeah
bang it out a little bit yeah it'll be
fine of a margarita go to you know
learners
you